Jo, absolut.
Bizarnt att ändå omsätta 100 miljoner på fyra fucking rupsig ryggsäckar, det är sjukt.
Och det som är ännu sjukare egentligen.
Varför har jag ens ansträngd för mig med olika produkter?
Det känns helt mer lös.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsätter 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dess bra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tunga ögonblick.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Stefanos pappa Johanå till podden och Stefanos får idag företräda bolaget Sig Säck.
Jag kanske borde fråga hur man uttalar det istället för namnet, men det är en väska, eller det är ett par väskor som på ganska kort tid har rullat upp i ganska många miljoner i omsättning.
Så idag ska vi följa den resan och innan du hoppar in här i podden Stefanos så ska vi kanske säga att du har grov gräs på hållen och jag har spenderat två dagar på en tung svensksa med en polare så att jag låter för jäkligt och du låter för jäkligt, men man får liksom vrida bort basen och överleva.
Hej och välkommen med det introet.
Ja men tackar, precis nu satte du ribban helt rätt för det här.
Rätt uttal på både mitt och bolagets namn med.
Var det det?
Ja men gott, fan vad härligt.
Kan vi inte få lite, förutom att du är känslig och allergisk som människa, kan vi få någon annan info om dig?
Ja men exakt, därmed vad ska jag säga, lite kort om mig, privat och gift, två barn, bor i lerum, utanför Göteborg i skogen av alla ställen, så att det är utkonstigt med allergier och grejer.
Ja, väldigt sportteknik, fiskeintressen, min bakgrund egentligen är ju systemutvecklare i grund och botten.
För många ärendens år sedan nu då, började med systemutveckling inom affärssystem och ERP.
Sedan har jag kört allt inom det spåret, både som egen konsult och gått in på apputveckling.
Rätt mycket IT-tungt i min historik.
Du håller ändå en hyggligt social och extrovert aura, kan jag ändå tycka.
Jag känner ju några systemutvecklare, de blir liksom trötta när de har snackat i en timme.
Kommer du gå och lägga dig efter detta?
Nej, det var ju egentligen det som gjorde att jag fick byta bana helt.
Jag är ju inte den här Dr.
Pepper-hörluran i någon jävla skrubb.
Det är inte riktigt jag.
Så jag bytte egentligen bana helt och hållet och kom in i konsultvärlden och du var egentligen där i att börja med B2B-försäljning och har hållit på med det i alla fall senaste tio plusåren nu.
Vad var det du gjorde som B2B-försäljning?
Jag började på Hooga ut i Stenungshund.
Okej.
Och började i Sälja.
Jag började egentligen i Supporten och hjälpte till att strukturera upp den men insåg ganska snabbt att det var ganska kul i kontakt med människor för som utvecklare så hamnar man ju i tredjedel led.
Alltså du får den spes, någon vill ha någonting så gör du det så blir alla nöjda och glada men du får aldrig någon kredj för någonting.
Så jag ville egentligen närma mig kund och kom in då på Hooga och sen började jag med ren försäljning till slut.
Vi fick några säljare som sjukskrev sig och så var vi tvungna att täcka upp för dem och sa ja men det är kul, det vill jag prova.
Och lyckades liksom bära upp både min egen och deras budgetar under ett halvårstid och tyckte ja men fan det här är jätteroligt.
Och så på den vägen är det jag träffade en jättebra chef.
Han bytte till Lernia och jobbade med uttidning av konsulter till framförall Volvo och den typen av bolag.
Så jag hoppade på där också och så har jag varit i konsultvärlden i princip de senaste tio åren också då.
Vi ska dra hur det är kopplad in i zigzag sen men men jag bara tänker att för dem som inte vet så Lerum är liksom mellanspåret mellan tågsträckan, Alingsås, Göteborg och vi som har pendlat där i några år, Stenningshund ligger också på den tågsträckan.
Vi som har pendlat där några år, vi undrar ju alltid varför någon bor i Lerum.
Och jag brukar aldrig fråga folk om de privata grejerna för det är relativt ointressant för de flesta.
Men finns det något spännande med Lerum?
Vi tar det som en tystnad och så går vi.
Ja exakt, jag är ju född och uppvuxen ut i Angered.
Så jag har ju alltid haft lite förort.
I venerna höll jag på att säga och vi letade ju ganska länge efterhus och så sa det att jag hade velat att barnen växer upp i en naturskön miljö som vi hade ut i Angered.
Det närmaste vi hittade efter två år det var Lerum och det var lite panikköp.
Nu hade vi en son på åtta månader och han kunde inte bo i en etta längre.
Så då blev det Lerum.
Det är väldigt fint därute.
Bra föreningsliv och så.
Det är det som lockar många barnfamiljer.
Jag kan uppleva att man lever två olika liv.
Först levde man i ett liv där man fullkomligt sket i sånt och nu lever man i ett liv där det är så här ja, det är så bra att uppstyra testdagar på fotbollen i den här byn.
Hälften vad trött man är som människa.
Man har olika prioriteringar så kan man ju lugnt säga.
Ja verkligen.
Vi ska ta, kan du berätta hur du kom in på zigzag sen?
För det var inte du som grundade utan du kom in där.
Nej, precis.
Jag kom egentligen in, det är så här, jag ska nog dra historien om zigzag först så att det blir tydligt också för alla lyssnare.
Zigzag är ju ett svenskt hårdmärke som tillverkar väskor för människor som vill ha lite mer organiserad och stressfri vardag.
Och vi vänder oss egentligen till människor som är på språng, alltså som är på väg.
Det kan vara till gymmet, till jobbet, någon weekenderresa eller du som nygift ska hälsa på svärföräldrar emellanåt.
Det är de vi vänder oss till.
Så en vanlig getaway över helgen liksom.
Och sen är det väl egentligen så att vi har designat de här väskorna för att skapa ordning i rörelse som vi säger då.
Och det är ju liksom, vi vill ju att man ska slippa stress och fokus eller ha ökat fokus liksom.
Och man kan väl egentligen säga så här att det grundades, idén till Zigzag kom ju redan 2014.
Och då var det ju grundaren som ju då inte längre gick kvar i bolaget.
Men han fick en idé, han jobbade som ljudtekniker och hade rätt mycket restdagar.
Och han hade all sin utrustning i en kameraveska.
Och där var det ju alltid ordning och reda och världens bästa struktur på saker och ting.
Men så fort han skulle packa sin resväska eller sin getaway-väska, så var det ju totalt kaos.
Och då tyckte han att varför finns inte det här på marknaden idag?
Finns det inte det?
Inte, jo det finns väl någon enstaka modell med den här karakteristiska sidöppningen, inte med flyttbara fördelare.
Okej, okej jag fattar.
Så då la han ner sin tid och skäl i detta under ett par år, designade fram den här väskan, var i Kina, tog fram en prototyp och sedan drog man egentligen igång det här med en kickstarter-kampanj från början.
Jag tänkte det, redan innan jag kollade upp det här företaget så var det såhär, det här är en sådan, du vet, draknästet eller kickstarter.
Om man går in och kikar så är det såhär, det här har alla ingredienser för den stilen.
Och jag gissar att den var framgångsrik.
Den var väl helt okej.
Oj okej, jajamän.
Det var inte riktigt där, eller det var inte där man fick traction.
Utan, om vi säger någonstans 2014 startade idén, färdutvecklad väskabolaget grundades 2018.
Då kom David Brude som är aktiv i bolaget nu, in som delägare.
Då tog man, man testade allt då, kickstarter-kampanj, man tog in professionella marknadsbyråer och så vidare, vi höll på i nästan tre år.
Men det begav sig inte.
Runt 2020 någonstans så fick David över det här bolaget själv.
Grundaren gick väl in i väggen, ville inte vara involverad med om jag säger så i alla fall.
Då fick David över bolaget med skulder och allt och kände att det här är en så bra produkt, det måste finnas en väg fram här.
Vad var det som gjorde att han tyckte att det var en så bra produkt, om han ändå försökt sälja någonting i så många år?
Grejen är att alla som hade ryggsäcken och testade, den tyckte att wow, den var riktigt bra.
Han kände väl att de inte hittat rätt väg att få till försäljningen och nå ut i rätt kanal.
Efter det så, vad blir det 2020?
Så 2021 denna gång kommer Johnny Persson in i bilden.
Johnny är då min svågel, så det är lite min väg in på Sig Säck, men jag kommer komma in på det lite senare.
Men han kom in, han körde i sin praktik, då fanns han pluggare på IOM, till e-commerce manager.
Den här första åren handlade det ju om att förstå Sig Säck och marknadsföring överlag.
Så det var en läroperiod.
Sen tog det egentligen traction någon gång.
Maj 2022, då började han realisera Skrinklan och sina learnings, och då fick det traction ganska fort.
Då var det olika annonser, då körde Al in på Meta och Google.
Det visade sig vara en bra plan.
Det blev ganska snabbt att man ökade successivt, även om det var på låga nivåer i början.
Så har det sett ut sen dess egentligen.
Det var tripplade omsättningar under ett par år, och nu ser vi ut att gå mot en dubblering i år.
Så på den vägen är det med Sig Säck.
Och för egen del, som sagt, jag är ju svågre med Johnny, har fullt honom i hans Sig Säck resa under ganska lång tid.
Var det lite boltlank till honom överlag i vissa frågor.
Och sen så hamnade jag förra året i maj mellan två jobb och sade att du nu kliade i fingrarna.
Och jag hade en idé om att jag skulle ta in fiskeutrustning från Asien.
Och sälja på europeiska marknader.
Och upptäckte ganska snabbt där att det går att förhandla med leverantörer i Kina.
På ett sätt som jag inte trodde var möjligt.
Och så frågade jag Jonny då, har ni förhandlat?
För de har ju haft samma producent under ganska lång tid.
Och då sa han, ja men vi har gjort det vi har kunnat och de har verkligen pushat fram och tillbaka.
Och då sa han, ja men ge mig ett par veckor, jag kan testa er.
Liksom, och source lite via Alibaba och så vidare.
Och se vad vi får fram.
Så på den vägen är det.
Jag kom in, jag gjorde det jobbet.
Och utan att gå händelserna i förväg så blir det ju ganska lyckat.
Så det är egentligen min väg in och sen så har jag en bakgrund inom försäljning och har sagt det att B2B-försäljningen har man ju inte jobbat så mycket med på SIGSAC tidigare.
Så det var ju en plan också att satsa på det senarefter då.
Men har ni dragit igång det?
Ja, nu på allvar egentligen i år.
Det var väl en period på ett halvår under 2024 där vi började titta lite på det.
Okej, det har varit nästan en uterslutande inbound försäljning.
Mycket förfrågan, alltså rena ordemottagning kan man exakt säga.
Och så sa vi att här finns ju någonting att gå på.
Och jag var ganska säker med tanke på hur bra produkten var, hur relativt enkelt det var att få människor att faktiskt vilja köpa produkten.
Att ha, jag tror på detta om vi gör det strukturerat och riktat.
Så det har vi ju börjat med i år då.
Kan vi inte, innan vi hoppar in på det så tänker jag ni, bara så att man får en förståelse, det är egentligen, om jag förstår rätt så är det egentligen typ fyra ryggsäckar ni säljer.
Det är fem numera men snart på onsdag när det här släpps avsnittet, då lanserar vi.
Jag förstår, då kommer det en femte.
Jag var inte så dålig på att räkna i alla fall.
Jag tycker att det är det.
Men, och det som är den, om man inte ser den framför sig, man kan öppna från sidan och det finns lite olika fack, och de är då flyttbara.
Om jag förenklar det här lite grann, jag fattar att du vill sälja in det på ett annat sätt kanske, men är inte det sjukt lätt att bara kopiera?
Är det inte jätteläskigt att bara ha fyra, snart fem produkter?
Jo, och det här var verkligen den stora utmaningen i början, och det man var rädd för.
Och det fanns ju mig i bakhuvudet hela tiden då, så ett sätt att motverka detta var ju tidigt, en idé om att skapa ett starkt varumärke.
För det skyddar ju en på något sätt mot Copycats.
Och vi fick faktiskt svar på det, för jag tror det var faktiskt under förra året, efter sommaren där någonstans.
Var det ett svenskt bolag så gjorde jag en exakt kopie på Organizer-väskan då, den.
Kul att det var ett svenskt bolag ändå.
Ja.
Hur dålig stämning var det när ni åkte dit pressa på?
Det blev det, och det rörde upp känslor, inte minst hos grunden, som ändå står bakom design.
Men det går ju inte att skydda, det finns inget patent att ta.
Men det som vi märkte ganska snabbt var att våra kunder var inne och kommenterade och kallade den för zigzag-kopian.
Det var ett kvitto på kundlojalitet.
Sen var det så att Johnny är en jäkel på marknadsföringen, det tog två veckor och det var slut på det roliga för dem.
Han hade tagit över deras digitala marknadsföring och snott i princip all trafik.
Så det visar att även om de skapade en Copia och den var billigare, så räcker det inte med en bra produkt.
Man måste förstå hur man ska sälja den.
Så idag är vi inte, jag skulle inte säga att vi är immuna mot Copia, det är inte det, men vi har jäkligt bra försvarsspel för det.
Hur ser marknaden ut för en sån här, har ni en hemmamarknad eller är det världen som är en hemmamarknad?
Ja, vi finns ju idag i Norden.
Där är ju Sverige och Norge, får vi väl ändå säga är våra hemmamarknader idag.
Sedan finns det ju både i Danmark och Finland också en bra marknad för oss.
Så vi började i Sverige och sen Norge.
Och där någonstans lärde vi oss vad som krävs för att gå in på olika marknader.
Sedan är ju alltid alla marknader unika och så vidare.
Men vi försöker, konceptet är att vi tar en marknad i taget.
Och det där tog ju ganska lång tid för några år sedan att göra.
Men idag har vi en hel mall och ett arbetssätt för detta.
Med färdiga nyckeltal för att se om det funkar.
Och vi sätter upp det ganska snabbt.
Det kan kosta oss kanske 30 000 och två tre dagar att sätta upp.
Sedan är vi inne på en ny marknad.
Och det tror jag är lite unikt för oss eller överlag att man är så snabb.
Men det finns vissa utmaningar i det.
Det är förstå, betalningssätt och fraktssätt och annat som funkar lokalt.
Men så fort vi, och vi har ju rätt typ av partners runt oss nu så att det går rätt fort att få fram den informationen och sätta upp det ganska fort.
Men det som vi har nere på tur nu då det är väl Polen som är närmast.
Jag tror att många kanske tänker på.
Men vi har ju en viss koppling.
David har ju lite pålack i sig och vatten är det rätt mycket.
Och vi känner väl igen målgruppen där nere.
Då ser du hur de använder väskor.
Och därför tror jag att det kommer att klinga ganska bra med hur vi marknadsför oss.
Exakt.
Och jag bara tänker, vad är liksom...
Det låter ju alltid som att, ja men det här är lugnt liksom.
Vi har en setup här och så kostar det 30k så är vi på plats.
Men ni har gjort en ganska fin...
Om man tar 2021, så omsatt ni 300k.
Och sen året efter, så omsatt ni 3 miljoner.
Och året efter är det typ 16,5.
Och då, nu gissar jag, var 2024 någonstans runt 30k.
Ja, 52k på slutet.
Okej, ja fan det var inte...
Ja okej, ja vad trevligt.
Jag trodde det var där dubblingen var.
Nej okej, ja då väntar vi på nästa.
Nej, den kommer i år, förmodligen.
Hur, det är ju lite halvbizarrigt att omsätta det på en ryggsäck liksom.
Vad, och när jag var inne här på er hemsida så är ju saker få i lager.
Det var någon som var slut i lager här någon dagen.
Nu är den tillbaka så ja.
Men, hur har liksom producenten hanterat den uppskalningen?
Och hur har ni betalat, ni måste ju få hem ganska stora ordrar för att väga upp det där.
Kan du inte ta mig igenom den logistiken lite?
Jo, absolut.
Bizargt då ändå att omsätta 100 miljoner på fyra fucking rybs i ryggsäckar, det är sjukt.
Och det som är ännu sjukare egentligen.
Varför har jag ens ansträngt mig med olika produkter, det känns helt menlöst.
För att göra det här ännu sjukare så ska jag säga att vår organiser och den 30 liters ryggsäcken står för 80% av denna omsättning.
Så de andra produkterna är en bråkdel i jämförelse.
Men producenten, jo så här, vi har ju haft lite tur och skicklighet i att vi har hittat en av världens största ryggsäcksproducenter ganska tidigt, vilket gör att kapacitet har ju liksom aldrig varit ett problem för producenten.
Och det som däremot har varit lite utmanande, det är ju, och det här är ju också helt bizarrt egentligen, men vi har ju aldrig träffat vårdproducent, vi har aldrig pratat med dem, utan allting har skett skriftligt på mail och så vidare.
Men ändå står vi här idag och är en av deras största kunder och de har sagt att de gärna vill komma till Sverige och hälsa på oss på ett kontor, vilket också är spännande för att vi har inget kontor.
Vi får lalona ditt, Joel, eller något.
Jag har inte heller kontor.
Men det är så mycket roliga grejer nu när man tänker tillbaka på hur man faktiskt nått hit då.
Men så här, vi har ju brottats lite under den här tillväxtresan och det största problemet stavas i likviditet.
Exakt, jag tänkte säga, hur fan har ni löst det?
Om man tripplar och så vidare.
Och det finns ju inga externa investerare här utan det är ju Davids envishet och en del privata pengar som har fått där att flyta i början och sen så har försäljningen gjort att, okej, vi klarar av att räkna ut ungefär hur stor tillväxt vi kan göra då.
Så det är ju självfinansierat.
Sen har vi ju, tack och lov, ändå lyckats medut av David, du är en jäkel på, han har ju bra kontakter och han är ju väldigt bra i att sälja in liksom CXAC som bolag tillfinansierade.
Så att vi har använt Weigh Logo Trade, precis som många andra gör, och den typen av aktörer för att brygga likviditetsutmaningar och så.
Men vi har ju lyckats nu då delvis för att vi faktiskt tagit detta och försökt hitta lite andra typer av leverantören, vilket vi lyckades med och vi lyckades producera väskan till 90-95 procent av kvaliteten mot vad vi har idag.
Vilket vi kände att vi vill vara hundraprocentiga.
Vi säljer ju liksom premiumväskor till ett bra pris.
Vilket har gjort att då la vi om taktiken istället för att byta leverantörer så gick vi ju tillbaka till våran och sa du, så är det läget, det här är våran resa vi har gjort, ni har sett, ni har varit med.
Det här är målet framåt, vad kan vi göra?
Och så visar vi upp då att vi har tillverkat väskor av likvärdig kvalitet.
Istället för att kanske droppa 30% i inköpspris som vi hade hoppats på, så kanske vi landar på hälften av det, men med bibehållen kvalitet då.
Och fick lägga om våra betalningsvillkor lite grann då, vilket har underlättat väldigt mycket för likviditeten.
Sen är det ju så här, vi har omget oss av jäkligt duktiga partners, vi har Joakim Kristensson på Speed som sköter hela vår logistik till och från Asien.
Det är en gubbetrö som du hade älskat, Johan.
Han är en riktig street smart gubbe och lyckas få hem grejer där man tror att det är helt omöjligt.
Men med hjälp av honom då och så och den här dialogen vi har haft med vår leverantör så har vi hela tiden lyckats tajma våra lager ganska väl.
Vi har gått egentligen från att ha jobbat ganska mycket just in time till att nu ha byggt upp kapital så att vi kan göra större inköp.
Så nu försöker vi täcka hela kvartal istället för månadsvis som vi har jobbat med innan.
Och det har ju faktiskt, tro det eller ej, blivit bättre för vår likviditet.
Vilket vi inte tog det från början, utan vi tog det att små, snabba skäppningar är mycket bättre.
Att ha grejer på sjön hela tiden och sådär.
Det är ändå sjukt imponerande.
Jag tror att alla som har haft en tillväxt på typ 20-25% vet ju om hur jävla svårt det är att få likviditet och räcka i lagerbindning.
Men att jobba med tripplingar och dubblingar på ändå hyggliga siffror, det är ju fullkomligt bizarrt.
Men ni har ju en fördel i att ni inte har så många skeer, så det blir ju inte så mycket hyllvärmare kan jag tänka mig, utan det blir liksom det som kommer in ska ändå ut.
Ja, vi flyttar på grejerna ganska fort, så är det ju.
Och vi har ju, den ena väskan finns i två färger, men där har vi också märkt ganska tydligt att det är ungefär samma fördelning, det är 80% svart, 20% blå.
Vilket ju är att det är nice det här, men det skapar mer problem och oreda än vad det gör nytta, förmodligen.
Nu nämnde du att när man har vuxit så bra och har den traction och det flowet, varför gör man inte exakt samma sak och skalar upp det?
Varför vill man in och peta med någonting nytt?
Är inte det bara att krångla till det?
Jo, vi separerar väl egentligen om man tänker D2C och B2B som två separata bolag i bolaget ungefär.
D2C modellen finns och den kör vi stenart på nu med en marknad i taget och så vidare.
Sen är B2B, det som är bra är att balansera upp för vi är ju ganska metatunga i D2C.
Det är mycket nykundsanskaffning och så där.
Och när den försäljningen viker, då är ju tanken att B2B ska kunna väga upp då med retail-åtförsäljare, rena business-to-business-bolag också då.
Så vi ser det egentligen som ett komplement, även om den, det är klart det finns potential att den ska kunna bli jättestor, men jag tror ändå att den kommer att vara en relativt liten del i förhållande till vår B2C, affäröverlag.
Jag tänker att det stora problemet är just det här nykunds...
Ni kan inte ha jättemycket återkommande kund.
Så här, vi har ändå relativt högt.
Vi ligger på runt 20 procent ungefär.
Okej, men varför ska de ha två rygsäckar?
Då är det väl egentligen så här tror jag.
Vi har till exempel kvinnor som köper först till sig själva, sen till sin man, sen köper man till sina barn.
Jag personligen, nu har jag ju Bayer såklart, men jag har ju för olika ändamål.
Hur många olika ändamål?
Jag har en för mitt fisk, jag kan ha en för när jag reser.
Jag vill inte att det ska lukta fisk i packningen.
Men sen är det väl egentligen såhär, ja vi lägger jättemycket pengar på marknadsföringen, så är det ju.
Det är ju definitivt den som håller nere resultatet på sista raden för oss.
Jag tror vi ligger på runt 5 procent hittills i år.
Vi tror oss kunna landa på 10 i slutet på året, men det som vi behöver få fart på, som har blivit lite lidande apropå lite flaskhalsar och utmaningar, är ju vår produktutveckling.
Vi vill ju få fram fler nya produkter och kunna testa av dem mycket mycket snabbare än vad vi har kunnat göra hittills.
Det finns en lång harang av anledningar där, men dels är vi ju ganska få i bolaget, vi är bara fyra pers, och då blir det ju lite grann så att någonting blir alltid lite lidande.
Produktutvecklingen har varit ett sådant område som vi har superfokus på nu i år.
Att kunna få fram nya produkter som höjer både OVU, men framförallt LTV för oss egentligen då.
Men tänker ni liksom rena väskor då, eller ska det vara mer åt tillbehör och utfyllnad, och typ en sovsäck?
Ja nej men både och egentligen.
Det kan vara resväskor som vi tittar på nu till exempel.
Ja just det.
Och revolutionera det.
Men också då, vad behöver du runt när du är på språng och du reser?
Det kan vara necessärt, det kan vara ja, det finns ju den typen av accessoarer som vi håller på att titta på.
Så det är inte bara, och sen tror jag det är svårt att få fram 2, 3, 4 sådana här hero-produkter som är väskor.
Det, även om det fanns en tanke om det från budget så har vi nog landat i att ja det blir nog jäkligt svårt att göra det.
Men definitivt breddas dokumentet.
Det är ju det vi tittar på nu då.
Varför väljer man att lägga, jag säger inte att det är fel, det är bara intressant, varför väljer man inte att typ, vi försöker med Tyskland, Polen och Nederländerna istället, här kan vi få nykunds, varför väljer man att splitta sitt fokus på det sättet?
Än så länge har ni bara varit på de här, alltså Sverige, Norge, Danmark, det är ju ganska små marknader.
Tyskland är vi, och det har vi varit ganska länge.
Så det som är med Tyskland är att det är ganska tuff konkurrens, vilket gör att nykunstens skaffningen där kostar betydligt mer än vad det gör på vissa andra marknader.
Sen är det ju lite grann hur redo vi är för att ta oss an den typen av marknader med att förstå betalningssätt och frakter och upprätthålla en bra leverans.
Vi tittar ju på Tyskland nu till exempel, där det är ju tyskarna väldigt måna om att man ska finnas på Amazon.
Så det tittar vi också lite grann på och ser hur vi kan ta oss an den biten.
Så att vi lär oss de olika marknaderna.
Så vi försöker ta de marknaderna som är mest likade om vi kan i dag, till och med lite lågt hängande frukter.
Det är lite så det CXAQA är som vi jobbar.
Vi försöker alltid göra allting superenkelt och ta det som är enklast först.
Det låter som att allting är guld och gröna skog här.
Vi har ju haft jätteutmaningar och konflikter internt och så vidare.
Inte minst för mig, jag kommer med en viss erfarenhet och så kommer det in e-handel, möts av helt andra tankar och idéer.
Så jag har fått bestämma att jag måste lägga min erfarenhet åt sidan, vilket är jäkligt svårt för att ta sig an någonting nytt.
Och acceptera att man vill bygga ett bolag på det här sättet och då får man acceptera det.
Och det vet ju du inte minst.
Du har ditt sätt att göra ditt bolag på och det är lite samma saker.
Och då får man på något sätt anpassa sig i detta.
Ja, jag köper det.
Det är så det funkar.
Och speciellt när ni är så få, då blir det ju väldigt, även om man kan vara en platt organisation så blir det ju, så här gör vi.
Ja, det är definitivt på det sättet.
Men någonstans är det också så här, det finns ju en grundtanke bakom hur vi vill utföra saker och ting.
Saker och ting ska gärna vara klart igår.
Och få med sig alla runt omkring.
Internat kan vi ju liksom, trimma in oss själva till så vi jobbar.
Men sen har vi partners och grejer runt omkring som kanske inte alls är vana att jobba på det sättet.
Och där blir det ju ofta en klasch då där vi kan vi testa en AI-chatbot i supporten.
Ja, men vi tittar på det nästa vecka.
Nästa vecka, nu.
Exakt.
Om två timmar har vi liksom en prototyp på detta.
Och där ibland krockar väl de här två världarna då.
Det har varit en väldig omställning för mig.
För jag har också kommit från den här lite trögflytande, det jag har tyckt att här jobbar vi och det går fort.
Det här är ju något helt annat.
Jag fattar.
För att bryta av från det, vad är Cigsac, är det ett väskbolag eller är det på språngbolag?
Ja, jättebra fråga.
Vi har ju brottat lite internt med detta, men vi har landat i att vi är ett resebrand.
För folk som är på språng, som behöver organisera sig i sin vardag.
Så är du på väg någonstans, det är då du vänder dig och tittar efter våra produkter för att organisera dig och se till att du har en slip i huvudverken när du ska någonstans.
Jag bara tänker på produktutvecklingen.
Jag fastnar ju där.
Jag vet att du tog massa andra diskussioner efter det, men jag fastnar ju där.
Jag funderar på vad blir nästa och det behöver du inte avslöja, men jag funderar på vad ingår i det.
Du hade ju en idé där, den fällbara flaskan.
Den har jag funderat på i två veckor.
Vad menar han?
Jag brukar ju skicka lite frågor inför poddarna och sånt där, och då var en av frågorna, kommer ni gå mer åt fler sorters väskor eller är det liksom accessoarer till?
Och då är liksom fällbar flaska vad det är jag gav som exempel.
Och jag bara tänkte att normalt sett är det ju en stor pettflaska eller liknande som man har, men den kan ju lika gärna gå och vara som ett dragspel.
Varför skulle den inte kunna vara så?
Och så att det är ett jävligt bra stänglås på den så att den aldrig droppar liksom.
För det är ju ofta det som är problemet och att den tar plats när man inte har den full.
Så det är de där två issues.
Jag bara undrade om det var åt det och jag skrev till exempel att man ska kunna ha batterier så man kan ladda mobilen i väskan så man kan fylla.
Men är det mer åt det hållet eller är det mer åt produkt?
Hade jag fått välja så hade vi gått mer åt det hållet.
Men vad kommer företaget göra?
Vi tittar väl egentligen på att hitta produkter som vi vet tilltalar, såklart den målgruppen inom recesegmentet som vi är.
Vi har ju fått det här bekräftat från våra partners också, som många som går in och satsar ganska hårt på recesegmentet överlag.
Och då har vi tittat på, det finns ju massor med tillvörd, det är liksom, jag nämnde tidigare, necessärer, det finns packkubor, både med vanliga färdigade påsar, vakumpåsar.
Det finns rätt mycket du behöver för att underlätta din resa och packandet.
Egentligen, och resväskor är ju någonting som vi håller på att titta på.
Där jag ser fram emot att få se en prototyp på hur vi kan göra det här, The Seek Seek Way, med det här smarta, enkla, genyna, som vi ändå är duktiga på.
Så jag skulle nog säga att vi tittar både på att försöka hitta nyheter och produkt, vilket ju är väldigt svårt, men framförallt hitta en bredd som höjer vårt Average Order Value över tid.
Exakt vad det blir, vi kollar även på olika färger och bredda våra skruor och så där, för det har vi fått en del förfrågningar på också.
Men man vet ju det också att många kunder säger ju att de vill ha någonting, men sedan köper de, det är en annan fråga.
Ja, så är det verkligen.
Du nämnde att ni ligger ju ganska mycket på nya kunder.
Har ni en kundgrupp som är er kundgrupp, eller har ni olika infallsvinklar till olika kunder?
Är ni ett, man hör ju mycket om de här Revolution Race till exempel, de säljer samma byxa fast i fyra olika kunder med olika reklam.
Här är för folk som går i skogen, här är för folk som ska ut och resa, här är för folk som är hantverkare, men det är samma byxa.
Gör ni samma sak eller har ni en kanal folk kommer igenom?
Jag tror vi har testat alla möjliga infallsvinklar, men det vi faller tillbaka till hela tiden, det är ju att det som triggar köp, det är människor som är på språng.
De är i någon form av tankeverksamhet kring att de ska göra en resa, eller någon form av getaway, det är där vi får våra köp.
Där har vi koncentrerat oss tillbaka på den typen av annonsering och budskap som vi vill lämna.
Man väljer att köpa den för att man skapar en resa, sen använder man väskan för olika ändamål, som man kanske inte tänkte på från början när man köpte väskan.
Där någonstans befinner vi oss nu då, att jag tror att det är uteslutande folk som vill göra någon form av resa, som köper våra väskor.
Ja, men jag köper det.
Jag uppfattade kanske fel där i början, jag uppfattade som att det var mest Norden, men du sa även Tyskland.
Vilka marknader är ni hyggligt stora på?
Ja, hemmamarknaden är ju Sverige och Norge.
Det är ju de största, de står väl för en 65 procent av omsättningen ungefär.
Kan ni se i de marknaderna, fortsätter det växa i de marknaderna?
Eller är det svårare att nå folk där nu?
Är det redan lite mättat?
Nej, mättat är det inte.
Sen är det ju så här, det går ju verkligen i perioder, har vi ju märkt.
Där försäljningen viker överlag och då slår det ju ganska hårt på de marknaderna vi är ganska starka i.
Men det växer ju fortfarande och vi har till exempel Finland och Tyskland som konkurrerar om tredje plats och det går liksom upp och ner beroende på omvärldsläge och vissa saker som vi kanske inte riktigt har förstått fullt ut än heller var det som påverkar.
Men sen är det ju så att vi kan testa av.
Vi har haft en EU-site där vi har kunnat testa av olika marknader för att se, okej, kan vi få någon inblick i vilken marknad vi ska gå på härnäst och så där.
Men syvende i sist handlar det nästan lite om magkänsla.
Det är lite det vi har gjort med Polen.
Till exempel nu då att vi tror på den här.
Att vi kan översätta vårt budskap på rätt sätt och så vidare.
Nu tappar jag bort med frågan varför de började.
I vilka marknader är de viktiga marknaderna jag jobbar mot?
Men då är det Sverige, Norge, Finland, Tyskland.
Och nu ska ni in i Polen.
In i Polen och in i UK är tanken på sikt också då.
Men det finns andra utmaningar med Brexit och sådana saker som man behöver ta hänsyn till.
Varför har ni inte tagit in lite cash från folk?
Det är en bra fråga.
Det finns ju en tanke från början.
Kalla det en princip då?
Att nej det här ska vara självfinansierat.
Vi vill inte ha in externa aktörer, vi vill inte ha in någon som in och petar och vänder och vrider i hur vi ska göra saker.
Det är redan tufft som det är mellanåt att vi ska komma överens internt.
Ha någon annan som in och petar i det här.
Är det du som är tuff att komma överens med eller är alla så?
Nej, nej.
Jag fick puffvillingen.
Ja, underbart.
Nej, det är verkligen inte så.
Det är inget som är svårt att komma överens med, det är bara det att det finns starka viljor och tankar hos våra två delägare för hur vi ska driva detta och då blir det ibland diskussioner i okej, är det här rätt väg att gå?
Hur...
Fan, vad du pratar diplomatiskt nu.
Nej, men alltså...
Det är ju det det handlar om.
Man måste ju vara diplomatiskt när vi är så få liksom.
Men så här, det är klart att vi har clashat ibland när vi ser på saker på helt olika sätt och det är ju fullt normalt och det är ju också det som har drivit bolaget framåt.
Men som sagt, ja, för mig handlar det då om att faktiskt ta ner garden lite igen och verkligen acceptera att okej, man får anamma det här sättet att driva ett bolag på.
Det är någonstans som vi alla har liksom linat nu, vilket ju gör att vi kan driva det här bolaget på så få pers som vi ändå är.
Ni är ju galet få, du sa väl att ni var fyra va?
Vi är fyra, ja.
Det är David då, som är en av delägarena, som har varit med egentligen från början.
Han har ju liksom en envishet och verkligen så här offrat rätt mycket för den idén han tror på.
Han jobbar ju då också som ansvarig för produktutvecklingen på CICSEC.
Han har ju varit entreprenör sen barnsben, som jag förstår det har varit inblandad i Fyndic och Cedion och så där när det blomstrar.
Han har ju galet med kontakter liksom.
Om David är i hjärtat så är väl Jonny i hjärnan då, i CICSEC.
Han är fantastiskt duktig på den digitala marknadsföringen.
Och ser saker som ingen annan ser ibland, vilket förundrar mig så.
Och kommer med en baknunder, det gick inte ens klart i utbildningen på IOM, för det gick väl lite för långsamt för honom, att satsa helhjärtat där på CICSEC.
Och så nu i år tog vi in Noel som jobbar som community manager på CICSEC.
Och det är också en jätteintressant grej, som jag tror är en del av framgångssagan egentligen, att vi satsar väldigt mycket på att vara synliga hos våra kunder.
Svara på alla kommentarer och DMs och så vi får.
På sociala medier ligger verkligen nära.
Och sen jobbar hon även med ditt favoritverk, då gjorde vi en med email marketing.
Så klart, så klart.
Och bidrar jättemycket runt det.
Bara att få in ett kvinnligt perspektiv också, i den här bubblan har jag gjort jättemycket.
Och bidragit till utvecklingen framåt.
Så det är det vi firar.
Sen har vi ett gäng kompetenta runt omkring oss såklart.
Vi har lagret i trollettan hos World 360.
Jätteduktiga och de sköter även kundsupporten för oss då.
Och så har vi Joakim på Speed som sköter hela logistiken till och från Asien.
En ekonomibyrå som vi jobbar med och så vidare.
Så vi har ju lyckats mycket för att vi har outsourcert verkligen rätt saker i rätt tid också.
Vad är nästa anställning?
Vad är det som folk börjar krångla över vet du?
Nej, det är faktiskt en bra fråga.
Alltså någonstans är ju fokuset på...
Det räcker med fyra.
Ja nej men än så länge gör du det.
Alltså så länge vi kan få igång produktutvecklingen att gå åt rätt håll så tror jag inte vi...
Ja, sen är det ju så här, jag menar på B2B, jag jobbar ju med lite lokala människor också, i Finland och Norge till exempel som hjälper mig.
Så där finns det ju möjlighet, jag menar om vi får det igång, B2B i Tyskland, så kommer det absolut behöva ett par lokala människor där som besöker och pratar med kunder, det blir alltid lättare.
Hur kan ni inte ha varit på plats hos leverantören eller producenten?
Jag bara tänker, om din första grej här var att va, ni måste kunna få ner de här priserna, det finns ju ingenting som får ner priserna så bra som att bara åka dit, då får man ju 3% ner direkt, det måste ju vara...
Det är väl flygerädda hela ögonen?
Nej, är det så?
Nej, det är en bra fråga.
Man gjorde väl, trodde man det man kunde när grunden var nere och satt i konceptet första gången, och sen har det ju försökt skriftligt lite fram och tillbaka, men jag tror, jag har jobbat mycket med förhandling, så för mig, jag ser det som en kul grej att faktiskt ta mig an en sådan utmaning.
Det har inte riktigt varit ett brio här, utan det har varit ett brio att faktiskt sälja och bygga ett varumärke i första hand.
Så nu när vi har nått dit, vi har nått, så kan vi börja titta lite mer på de här sakerna.
Så det är ju inte långt ifrån att vi tar det här besöket, antingen om någon kommer hit eller om vi åker dit, vi har ju redan börjat prata om det nu då.
Men det är ju rätt fantastiskt att det har funkat utan ett sånt besök.
Ja, det är lite halvbesökt faktiskt.
Har det varit mycket problem under den tiden?
Har det varit många ansändningar som har varit, fan här är en dragkedja som saknas.
Det händer emellanåt.
Men där har vi nog haft lite tur också.
Det är klart att vissa saker har varit problematiskt, man har glömt att montera en bröststrap på ett 10-20-talet väskor, med avvita att kort skicka, fått kompensation.
Så det har alltid löst sig, de har alltid varit väldigt till mötesgående många gånger när det kommer till kvaliteten.
När det kommer till affärsvillkoren, I need to talk to my manager.
Alltså det är klassiska.
Så, men nej, annars har vi, tycker jag att det har funkat väldigt bra.
Vi har alltid fått så genom åren att om vi har något klagomål som de löser, så då svarar de liksom inom en kvart typ.
De bara, ja men det löser vi här, skickar vi ut åtta nya displayer.
Men ibland när man mailar så bara, får man inget svar.
Och så tar man upp det vid nästa beställning så, ja, apropå det, den här var ju felsvetsad, inget svar.
De svarar på resten men inte det.
De bara, fullkomligt blockar ut det.
Det tycker jag är det mest fascinerande med att jobba med produktion.
De bara, nej, den här frågan väljer vi och bortser ifrån.
De kan ju göra så och så med ifrån, vi kan ju inte byta.
Det är ju det som är lite farligt, att liksom hamna i ett läge där man blir tagen för givet, vilket jag tror det handlar om att göra sig lite obekväm.
Även om man månar om såklart bra relationer med alla sina partners, så är det ju ändå viktigt någonstans att förstå att det är ju business i slutändan.
Ja exakt, de behöver göra det som är bäst för företaget någonstans.
Ja, en sista fråga där lite grann eller ett sista ämne.
Nu har ni haft en god tillväxt och kommit även upp på lönsamhet och så där.
Hur gör man för att inte, hur gör ni för att bibehålla det momentumet och fortsätta göra ett grej som inte bara blir, okej nu har vi kommit igång, nu har vi kommit upp, nu helt plötsligt ska vi ha tusen olika nya saker.
Vi tar fram fem nya produkter, det har skett sig här i Trean Jamai, du vet, hur håller ni er fokuserade, vad är, hur går tankarna där?
Så här, vi har en ganska tydlig bild internt om att vi måste få in fler produkter.
Det är liksom den teorin vi går efter, att vi behöver bredda.
Dels då för att kunna exploatera vidare på de marknader vi redan är starka på, och sen handlar det om att ta sig in på en ny marknad i taget, få den att snudra, och sen jobba vidare egentligen då.
Sen parallellt med detta då, jobba fram en vågskål i vår B2B affär, som ändå kan hjälpa oss att hålla upp volymer och annat, om försäljningen viker i vår D2C, vilket den tenderar till att göra emellanåt.
Och det är ju inte det, vi påverkas ut precis som alla andra gör, av vissa omvärldsfaktorer och så där.
Och sen är det ju då enormt tydligt fokus internt på vilka arbetsuppgifter vi faktiskt ska fokusera på.
Det är ju lätt att man blir allt i allo när vi är så få.
Och det är ju någonting vi brottas med dagligen, att faktiskt kunna prioritera det som är viktigt att göra.
Och klara av att hålla det, och samtidigt bygga vidare på vår community och jobba vidare med micro-influencers och annat som vi jobbar med, så tror vi ändå att då kan vi fortsätta växa.
Visionen är ju liksom att 2026 ska vi ju nå en kvarts miljard.
Det är rätt häftig vision.
Ja, verkligen.
Och på något sätt blir det ett globalt varumärke.
Det finns liksom inga tankar på någon exit och så heller.
Utan det är en bebis som vi försöker ta hand om och bygga upp.
Jag tror att det finns någon sådan här liten dröm om att segla upp och bli ett sådant här globalt varumärke och ha gått lite under radan.
Att inte, jag menar, synas all för mycket i offentligheten och i de här kretsarna.
Vi har ju varit ganska under radan under lång tid.
Ja, ni kanske har varit det.
Det är bara för att jag tror att jag har följt dig på LinkedIn under lång tid.
Det kanske är därför jag har sett det då.
Men okej, det kanske ni har varit.
Absolut, absolut.
Då hoppas jag att ingen på Break It hör detta och skriver om det när bokslutet kommer ut sen.
Det har väl varit något omlännande i Break It någon gång så.
Men det var ganska skigga i offentligheten annars.
Då tackar jag lite extra mycket för att jag fick möjligheten att intervjua dig här.
Stort tack Stefan-Oss för att du var med.
Tack så mycket.
Lerum är liksom mellanspåret mellan Tågsträckan, Alingsås, Göteborg.
Vi som har pendlat där några år, vi undrar ju alltid varför någon bor i Lerum.